olá pessoal no pão
vocês me ouvem é eu vou começar a me
conectar com vocês
contando três histórias que eu
colecionei ao longo de 25 anos de
magistério
eu comecei a lecionar em cursinhos
preparatórios para vestibular aos meus
18 anos de idade não deveria ter feito
isso há 18 anos mas enfim
a situação me levou a isso e desde então
eu venho não selecionando mas também
colecionando algumas histórias que eu
acho que são os pichadores e essas três
histórias me levam a pensar sobre o tema
dessa fala que é o impacto que as
desigualdades socioeconômicas causam nas
realidades conexas
a primeira história ela é uma pergunta
que um aluno me faz a final de uma aula
uma aula sobre democracia ateniense e ao
intervalo ele me pergunta o seguinte e
sem nenhum tipo de questionamento que
não o acadêmico
ele me perguntou o professor mendigos
os abrigados moradores de rua eles são
cidadãos e eu vou guardar essa pergunta
por enquanto porque ela vai ser
completada por uma segunda pergunta
feita numa outra aula por uma outra
pessoa mas que também levou uma reflexão
ea pergunta foi professor ciclistas
deverão utilizar as ruas com os mesmos
direitos dos motoristas que são
proprietários de carros e uma terceira
questão que foi colocado também e
curiosamente tudo mais ou menos no mesmo
período no mesmo ano foi professor
pessoas pobres que não têm renda
deveriam freqüentar shoppings centers
essas três questões foram colocadas em
sala de aula e sem nenhuma maldade por
parte de quem fez com uma legítima
curiosidade é interessante porque elas
vieram no mesmo ano um ano em que três
eventos acontecerão na cidade de são
paulo
o primeiro evento foi uma ação da
prefeitura municipal no bairro da luz na
região da luz também conhecida como
cracolândia e que levou a um processo de
espalhamento de dependentes químicos e
desabrigados por toda a cidade
eu comecei a notar que algumas pessoas
estavam incomodados com isso porque não
conheciam essa realidade não tinha
contato com essa realidade estavam
desconectadas deste problema via
obviamente as notícias mas não tinha um
contato de fato com aquilo visual ou
físico
o segundo evento da segunda pergunta a
polêmica das ciclofaixas e ciclovias em
são paulo e houve essa questão um
sentido de muitos deles acharem que os
ciclistas não deveriam utilizar o espaço
público da rua eo terceiro a questão
daqueles que não têm poder aquisitivo
nos shoppings por conta dos rolinhos em
um evento também muito marcante na
cidade de são paulo
o que eu retirei de tudo isso que essas
três perguntas remontam a um ponto
fundamental na questão das desconexões o
tratamento do conceito de cidadania como
sinônimo de consumo porque na primeira
pergunta feita sobre se o desabrigado o
mendigo é cidadão e estende o devolve a
pergunta para o aluno as porque ele não
seria a resposta foi porque ele não paga
impostos e se ele não paga impostos não
tem direito a que percebi que ali um
problema começava a se formar o
tratamento de direitos como mercadorias
só poderiam ser consumidas por aqueles
que têm renda
na segunda pergunta que lhe foi feita
sobre o ciclista também devolve a
pergunta mas porque não poderia utilizar
a rua e conviver com o motorista o que o
motorista pague pva e tva lhe dá o
direito de usar a rua o ciclista não e
aparentemente então só quem paga ipva e
imposto nem é pra isso não é só quem
pode pegar tem o direito de ir e vir nas
ruas asfaltadas ou nem tanto no caso de
são paulo e o terceiro ponto o dos
inglesinhos mas o que essa pessoa vai
fazer em shoppings ela não tem dinheiro
para consumir e isso me levou essa
reflexão
então nós temos um ambiente no qual uma
sociedade que trabalha a cidadania os
direitos que pelo menos desde o
iluminismo deveriam ser tratadas como
fundamentais e universal
como produtos de consumo e chamados
conexão muito forte de realidades
eu trabalhei grande parte da minha vida
em cursinhos privados com mensalidades
caríssimas
é óbvio que essa desconexão se
manifestou nesse momento a famosa teoria
das bolhas
isso me leva a pensar em duas
consequências imediatas desse pensamento
primeira consequência que me chama a
atenção além dos direitos serem tratados
como produtos e portanto como fruto
exclusivo daqueles que podem consumir
cria se também uma idéia de que se você
não tem renda dinheiro você é
responsável por não ter acesso aos
direitos
criamos um processo de culpabilização
hora eu tenho havendo eu posso consumir
você não o quase uma lógica de uma
seleção hunter doente natural ou para
utilizar a o prefixo aqui desde natural
você não conseguiu por características
suas você não merece ser cidadão
isso me choca mas me leva também a
outras duas conclusões prévias sobre
esses exemplos que eu sinto por vocês
uma primeira conclusão é de que
aparentemente como professores ou eu
estou errando em sala de aula ao não
conseguir demonstrar para os meus alunos
que o ser
ele é o elemento que nos conecta em
entre relações e o ter não ao tratarmos
os direitos como produtos
a impressão que eu tenho é que o consumo
imediato do bem material se aplica ao
outro e cria se uma sensação de
competição de competição porque a
impressão que se dá na sociedade que
vivemos é que os direitos são
privilégios são para poucos e isso vem o
conceitual que cometemos a todo momento
o direito só será direito quando ele for
universal pelo menos os fundamentais e
não tratados com este permite de
exclusividade que esconde na verdade a
desconexão que temos
com o outro que vive uma realidade
distinta da nossa e sim em sala de aula
eu notei isso em cursinhos particulares
eu também tive uma experiência como
professor em supletivos quando comecei a
lecionar aos meus oito anos de idade
eu trabalhei primeiramente em supletivos
e eu era mais jovem da sala o que parece
ser paradoxal porque um jovem recém
ingresso na universidade de cabelo
raspado dando aula para pessoas de 45 50
55 anos de uma realidade completamente
desconexa da minha eu dava aula para
pessoas que trabalhavam em vários
empregos metalúrgicos domésticas
faxineiros frentistas e eu comecei a
lecionar na 5ª série do ensino médio
hoje seria o sexto ano se não me engano
e que feito o primeiro bimestre no
supletivo que é muito condensado
chegaram as primeiras provas e as provas
montei as provas aplicando a prova o
professor aplicar a prova na sala de
aula ea sala pequena 15 alunos foi se
esvaziando em 30 e 50 minutos e um aluno
sobrou um aluno ficou sentado na última
carteira me lembro até hoje no canto
superior da sala
o nome dele era parlos um senhor
simpático cimo dos seus 60 anos de idade
e eu vi o carlos olhando a prova sem
conseguir resolvê la
o meu universo o universo marcado pelo
vestibular pela questão da cobrança do
conhecimento que serve para responder
apenas uma alternativa como se a
realidade fosse feita apenas de uma
alternativa é me levou a um julgamento
prévio é uma desconectam com ele
pensei 'acho carlos um estudo para a
prova e consequentemente está perdido
aqui mas me aproximei do carlos e
perguntem eu chamava cosme de carlão na
época era grande porque não tudo bem e
sem levantar os olhos
ele fala não tá tudo bem foi meu querido
você não estudou ele diz não estudei mas
eu não consigo escrever quando ele disse
eu não consigo escrever novamente a
linha de conexão com ele eu pensei meu
deus será que ele não sabe escrever e
que pertençam a minha confundir não
conseguir com não saber
quantos de nós não sabemos coisas mas no
momento de executar não conseguimos por
uma série de fatores
eu disse mas como assim você não
consegue escrever e presumindo a
história obviamente ele conta que há
cinco ou seis anos antes daquele momento
ele tinha sofrido uma isquemia cerebral
e perdeu a capacidade de coordenar os
movimentos
no momento o que o protocolo mandava que
eu fizesse uma desculpa então você vai
ter que procurar a coordenação uma
orientadora pedagógica da sua prova em
branco ac
a toyota 0 mas o preferido entre
relacionar com ele sempre queria e além
de me conectar naquele momento e eu
propus o seguinte para ele tudo bem
carlos foi o seguinte e do planeta na
prova digital a questão de dar resposta
tipo é contigo para resposta vou
escrever textualmente que você falar sem
nenhum tipo de correção pode ser ele não
professor vai tomar seu tempo carlos lá
ele fez isso
lembro até hoje a nota dele foi 76 e ter
feito isso
passado mais algum tempo na mesma sala e
já no próximo ano porque no supletivo
nets cada semestre um ano então eles
tinham sido aprovados e era meu
aniversário e no meu aniversário eu
recebo de presente naquela sala um
conjunto de canetas lapiseiras que tem
até hoje guardado e inclusive comenta
pra vocês um detalhe emotivo fiz questão
de elaborar esse tese essa fala usando
essa caneta que eles me deram porque
mais importante do que o objeto caneta
talvez como o grão de café tenha sido o
significado daquilo e quando perguntei
pra ele se chama o sociólogo a gente
pergunta porque para tudo não dois mais
dois é igual a quatro ou cinco para o
debate além do debate
então eu pergunto sempre tá eu perguntei
pra ele pra ele pra sala que lhe deu 80
mil carros
eu perguntei mas porque a caneta eo colo
respondeu porque é o seu instrumento de
trabalho e você se conectar com a gente
pelo saber pelo conhecimento também
simboliza a nossa conexão
eu sou muito chorão obviamente que
naquele momento eu me desfiz em lágrimas
né
e é legal porque quebrou um pouco aquela
bolha de desconexão entre professor e
aluno
e terminando essa ilustração
isso aconteceu em são carlos nos idos de
infelizmente eu não sei se o carlos é
vivo ainda ou não mas sempre que eu ia a
são carlos e passava pela pastelaria que
ele tinha ele fazia questão que eu
parasse começo um pastel tomasse uma
coca e bradava contava a história pra
todo mundo que estava lá
se isso não é uma conexão de duas
realidades distintas a minha dele eu não
sei o que é
então onde queria chegar com tudo isso é
óbvio que as questões socioeconômicas
elas impactam em realidades conexas
ainda mais numa sociedade como a nossa
que marcada pela velocidade pela
aparente outra conexão nas vezes eu me
recuso a acreditar que uma tela fria e
gélida de celular estabelece uma conexão
de fato ela pode saber se uma pré
conexão nós nos conhecemos aqui via
celulares
nós estamos agora concretizando isso é
tão novo que esse cenário traz uma
ansiedade em desespero e uma noção de
consumismo que impede a leitura de três
pontos
os direitos só serão direitos quando
universais
um segundo ponto um outro que está à
minha frente não é necessariamente um
concorrente
nós vivemos em uma sociedade
compartilhamos espaços
compartilhamos experiências não há como
considerar o outro essencialmente como
um concorrente
essa na minha concepção é uma visão
filosoficamente eticamente desconecta do
que somos enquanto seres humanos
me recuso a acreditar que rock está
certo que o homem é o lobo do homem eu
prefiro acreditar em russo e que temos
uma perspectiva de idade humana que se
desenvolve nas relações chamada
sociedade e um terceiro ponto e aí eu
empresto um pouco as palavras de hebert
vianna que acha uma pessoa extremamente
sensível quando ele dizia uma de suas
músicas e suas letras que o céu de ícaro
tem mais poesia que galileu e acho que
essa frase nos traz uma dimensão muito
bonita
é ser humano os seres se fazem conexão
as aparentes de conexões que tanto se
falam sobre os cenários socioeconômicos
são importantíssimas mas digo a parentes
porque apesar de materialmente reais
elas podem e devem ser superadas por
exemplo que estão sendo colocados aqui
nesta visão por exemplo que trabalha em
uma filosofia que trabalha em uma
espiritualidade e que trabalham
fundamentalmente à saúde pois um corpo
são uma mente triste tenderá a não
exercer aquilo que somos como humanos
ou seja os seres que vão muito além de
uma simples realidade física
então convido a todos para que numa
próxima experiência como essa
aparentemente tão desconecta entre
amigos entre pais e filhos entre casais
lembrem-se nenhuma conexão nasce pronta
nós temos que partir de uma desconexão
para a construção daquilo que chamamos
de conexão
muito obrigado